welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of
everything that you might have missed in
the new morbius trailer which packs in
non-stop marvel easter eggs on every
visible surface really the best hype man
for a vampire trying to get into an mcu
party i don't know if i should let him
in it looks like he wants to suck my
blood yeah sure but he's friends with
multiple spiderman spiderman villains
spiderman newspapers spiderman
skyscrapers and he gets a tan beefy bot
out of nowhere like spiderman did so you
gotta let him in okay whatever i'm sure
i won't regret this enough bits there is
so much to break down not just the big
marvel easter eggs but some more subtle
details that could clue you into this
studio's bigger plan for how all of
these titles may be connected to the mcu
in spider-man no way home so let's get
started
do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
the trailer opens with a helicopter
lifting morbius and some equipment into
a remote jungle island that chopper's
numbered in 9747p
which is actually a common stock
registration number seen on aircraft in
a lot of movies cars 2 casino royale
it's really the bart the bear of movie
aircraft numbers
every movie with a bear in the 80s and
90s that was part anyway this pilot
kindly asks if he needs a doctor but dr
michael morbius is like f you dude i am
a doctor okay jeez this paints morbius
as a determined but abrasive intellect a
physician in spite of himself unable to
find a better doctor to fix his ailment
yes a doctor in the vein of doctor
strange may be soon literally in his
veins
moving on
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure so in the comics dr
michael morbius has a rare blood
disorder that he tries to correct with
vampire bat serum and electrotherapy
that turns him into a living vampire who
isn't technically the immortally undead
variety since his powers came from
science not the bite of a vampire he was
introduced as a spider-man villain who
also ends up tying in with glade but
here we flash back to morbius as a
younger man in a ward with other
children with medical conditions
actually the first trailer showed this
same room with michael and only one
other kid a blonde boy who i think is
going to end up growing up to be matt
smith's character loxius crown who will
have a similar condition curing it in a
similar way giving him vampiric powers
making him a parallel figure villain of
the story you and i are more alike than
it seems actually in that other shot the
ward was completely empty aside from
those two as michael set up a game of
chess probably metaphorically setting up
the mental game of chess between the
hero and villain but also suggesting
that all these other kids might have
died off or maybe they're just playing
outside yeah yeah can that be it please
now in the comics crown becomes the
villain hunger with his own vampiric
powers but this is not to be confused
with hunger the devourer of realities
that's the universal scale parasitic
force from the jim starlin thanos comics
it's a completely different thing lots
of things can be hungry folks like matt
smith isn't playing a marble eating
hippo adult michael is cared for by
martine bancroft and we see his more
vulnerable gentler side a doctor trying
to cure not only himself but others all
over the world including sweet little
anna here who draws pictures of a sun
over the ocean with a second son behind
it making a silly emoji face she's the
best and more importantly she knows
there are multiple realities with
multiple sillier worlds colliding with
each other so save her dr morbius we
need her moving on we have to push the
boundaries take the risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
morbius slices his hand as he stands
inside this cage with harp-like wires
that and the overhead shot of the swarm
you can see glowing blue meaning it's
emitting a special frequency that
attracts these bats it's not the blood
that's drawing them in it's the
frequency this actually might remind you
of hooper trying to attract the shark in
jaws by putting himself in a cage in the
water you go in the cage cage goes in
front of the cave bats in the cave
[Music]
you've been missing for two months then
you were found on a container ship that
washed up off a long island
now the music in this trailer is the
doors people are strange a song that
also features prominently in the vampire
film the lost boys jim morrison's words
evoke the loneliness dr morbius now
feels as a living vampire but we also
cannot help but draw a connection
between the strange folks currently
tampering with reality in a way that
might have caused these multiversal
incursions tyrese gibson's playing simon
stroud here an fbi agent investigating
morbius but in the comics a vampire
hunter who tries to hunt him down this
container ship incident may be based on
morbius's origin and the amazing
spider-man 101 when he slaughtered
everyone aboard a ship and horrified by
his actions actually tried to commit
suicide but it didn't work and you gotta
love that classic horror imagery here
some blood dripping on the hand from the
monster above this kind of thing we've
seen in silence of the lamps jurassic
world this also reminds me a lot of
aliens but this may remind you of the
blood dripping from peter parker's arm
in the first sam raimi spider-man and
nearly fell on norman osborne but
instead made the loudest splat ever
[Music]
next clip what did you do to yourself
doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever so in the new york skyline is
the horizon building horizon labs is
from the spider-man comics this is a
facility where peter parker tinkers on
his iron spider armor later leading to
the alchemix corporation which is how we
get spider-man 2099 miguel o'hara but
also in the comics peter parker takes dr
morbius here this could be a place where
maybe the two people meet but they do
include the rising sun logo here which
could be connected to those rising suns
of anna's drawings i'm obsessed with
these could she be a horizon test
subject suffering from an experiment
gone awry it's all connected now here
the horizon building is not far from
another building that is under
construction which we know from the
other nighttime skyline shot there's the
under construction tower right beside
the oscorp building now we last saw
ozcorp tower in the amazing spider-man 2
in 2014 the andrew garfield mark webb
series and it has the same exact os corp
logo that broken r in the incomplete p
that actually kind of makes it look like
a question mark invoking the mysterious
nature of this company but of course
that tower had a different structure and
had the word oscorp running up the side
of it not at the top like this so in a
way this is both a nod to the andrew
garfield universe but also in a
completely different form i don't know
maybe oscorp is expanding by acquiring
various shell ventures lots of the city
skyline just to give corporate backing
for all kinds of spidey adjacent
villains that sony plans to roll out
like black cat and rhino and craven the
hunter actually we know from a set photo
from this movie that there's gonna be a
craven catering truck somewhere in there
so it seems like sony's suggesting
morbius could be taking place in a kind
of merged shared universe perhaps on the
other side of doctor strange's spell in
spider-man no way home but my issue is
morbius was originally intended to come
out like a year before no way home was
going to at least certainly before
venom's reality warped teleportation in
the let there be carnage post-credits
scene really i think the easiest way to
interpret this cause and effect logic is
that the multiverse has already been
merged in various chaotic ways that we
just haven't noticed before doctor
strange's spell in no way home that
wasn't what broke it lots of things have
been causing these incursions and that
was just the final straw that broke the
camel's back because we did learn in
loki that according to kang time is a
flat circle what we understood to be
cause and effect really just needs to be
thrown out the window essentially the
multiverse is destined to scramble and
therefore will have always been
scrambled as it is now in physics this
concept is called pascal's omelet let's
move on it worked not exactly i have
increased strength and speed
and some form of bat radar
what else can i do so morbius releases
sonar bursts like a bat does i like how
from its perspective it causes the
surfaces to swirl with this fluid smoky
texture transforming walls and floors
from hard surfaces that would hurt his
fragile body if he were smack into them
to now a more amorphous environment that
he could just kind of float through on
morbius's chalkboard are some letters
referring to the base pairs in a dna
protein strain but actually to the left
is written pkb37 pkb49 etc etc these are
actually all weights of silver silver is
of course a weakness to werewolves and
in a lot of vampire fiction to vampires
as well perhaps morbius was testing what
weights of silver have the strongest
effect on him now and then on his desk
in front of him is an open textbook on
bats and an empty blood bag michael
morbius did you just sip blood out of
that boba tea straw tube and then he
lifts a massive stone tomb you know
these things that medical doctors leave
lying around their offices and then he
booms his echolocation across the city
you can see it's honing in on this green
and red skylight window it's hard to
tell what building this is but it does
give off some kind of red glow on the
left side as the burst passes it making
me think this could be the horizon
building that has a similar red glow but
there's also a tall construction crane
to the upper left so this might be near
that under construction tower beside
oscorp really i just think morbius's
final battle will go down with luxy's
crown and his allies at oscorp and or
horizon maybe to retrieve a serum that
can help patients like anna next clip
[Music]
okay here morbius wearing his orange
prisoner jumpsuit so i'm guessing this
is part of his escape from police
custody uses his powers in a subway
tunnel you'd see the sonic energy
flowing past him as he's in a wind
tunnel his earlobes wrinkle over like
those of a bat i suppose which looks
like they're reacting to the sound but
it's worth noting that our earlobes
aren't the part of our body or bat
anatomy that absorbs the sound through
the tissue that is actually the inner
ear an auditory nerve mammal ears have
these funnel and cone shapes to direct
sound inward but whatever i guess the
wrinkling makes him look more bat-like
and as he floats ahead of the subway
train you can see someone running after
him on the platform it looks like al
madrigal's character fbi agent rodriguez
but it also does match the shot of matt
smith later on in the trailer on this
train platform he might be in this
location too i'm wondering if this
sequence might play out like the new
york subway scene in the movie ghost
remember when patrick swayze finally
learns to channel his undead powers and
i just mentioned ghosts because it is
really the only film i can think of to
successfully mix the tones of
supernatural horror with comedy and
action and romance and morality play as
this movie morbius living vampire is
trying to do it looks like god that
scene and ghost with vincent schiavelli
is that tragic subway ghost terrifying
his mental breakdown just
that's a mephisto doing a chef's kiss
because the movies and tv shows haunt my
dreams and ruin my sleep now are you
looking for a gift that keeps giving
year-round give your friends and family
a scent bird subscription scentbird is a
flexible fragrance subscription service
that lets you shop from over 600 brands
scentbird lets your recipient choose a
new designer fragrance to try every
month they have perfumes and colognes
and a lot of unisex options so this
month i received the skyler salt air the
arquisit nun bun and the mercedes-benz
sign this is what they look like they
come in these cool little tubes that you
just twist and you left out this
mercedes-benz scent is really nice
yeah it's got this crisp citrusy vibe
that definitely makes you feel like
you're riding in a fancy car excuse me
my um my lady's calling it easy easy
easy so again yeah it's got this cool
dispenser system you just twist it's out
and you can spray it right away or you
can lift out to see what it is it's just
like the perfect amount you need to
really try it out and it's a really good
amount of scent it is eight times the
amount of a normal sample so with each
fragrance whoever you get the sword will
get a 30-day supply so they can try out
fragrances before committing to a full
bottle they offer three six and 12-month
gift subscription options is a gift set
more of their speed well check out
scentbird's perfume and cologne gift
sets filled with fan favorites from
gucci dolce gabbana and many more
designers or treat yourself with our
code it's only 11 for your first month
so make sure to use code nr for 30 off
your first month at scentbird.com it's
just 11 for your first month and now
scent bird is available in canada so go
ahead and sign up moving on
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of him
he wants to hunt
and consume blood
here we see morbius in a blood bank
resisting the urge to guzzle it all down
now notice the audio of morbius's line
sounds a bit edited there's something
inside of me who wants to hunt and
consume blood yeah someone chopped that
together almost sounds like the words
consume blood was spoken by another
character almost like crown finishing
morbius's sentence for him because he's
also a vampire next clip and you control
it
i don't know
half the city wants to kill you we
haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco the great
jared harris appears as michael's mentor
figure perhaps the character emile nicos
from the comics who is part of dr
morby's past as a kid from greece then
there's this crime scene from that
subway station overseen by agent stroud
and rodriguez with these dead patrol
officers yikes i'm thinking morbius
could have fled into the subway when he
escaped but then crown might have killed
these cops to make it look like it was
morbius and did this also to hide his
own vampiric powers but in the big
detail morbius reads a daily bugle
newspaper with the same print edition
masthead from the sam raimi spider-man
movies and from venom let there be
carnage headline dr michael marbeus
apprehended for vampire murder
underneath in a shocking turn of events
world-renowned medical genius dr michael
morbius has been arrested for murder and
then above it three teaser headlines
finding the truth within told in his own
words rhino on the loose zoo hoax fools
us all and black cat friend or foe now
you can definitely read these as teases
for the existence of spider-man villain
black cat felicia hardy in this universe
party was actually played by felicity
jones in the 2014 film and sony has been
planning a black cat spin-off movie for
years and then of course spider-man
villain rhino who was played by paul
giamatti as a man in an armored suit in
the 2014 film though this headline
reports it as a zoo hoax i don't know
what that is so it might just be a wink
for us but i am sorry to do this but as
a nerd with a journalism degree this
newspaper is straight up goofy remember
the print version of the bugle from the
other movies was a tabloid with a
splashier full photo cover with inlaid
block text of course a parody of the new
york post this version has the classic
serious journalism six column layout
more text based like the new york times
with a serif text headline above the
photo yet despite this more serious
design the wording is full of bad
practices even j jonah jameson wouldn't
allow dr michael morbius apprehended for
vampire murder is grammatically
nonsensical is it saying morbius
murdered a vampire or is himself a
vampire who murdered someone or murdered
someone in the way of vampire wood i'm
sorry but these are the details
newspaper editors are obsessed with
j-jonah jameson would totally be like
way too many words use two or three max
like you would never waste six columns
of ink on a long vague verb like
apprehended when actually ethically
journalists are supposed to use verbs
like arrested or charged for active
investigations and definitely not put
the word murder in the headline even
when quoted by presumably police you
wouldn't report his name as dr dr
michael morbius in the headline and then
in the lower graph the full word doctor
michael morbius i mean really a more
appropriate headline would be something
like nobel winning doctor arrested under
charges of vampire-like killings which
is more clear and obviously more
scandalous right because he has won a
nobel you would put that in the headline
and then you would print his name in the
lead sentence of the article i know i
know movies are filled with professional
inaccuracies sure sure but every time
the daily bugle had shown up in a sony
movie they have been weirdly fixated on
the whole media industry side of it like
let there be carnage is all about toxic
relationships between true crime
reporters and their subjects in the
rainy trilogy jj jones jameson
absolutely pushes overly salacious
headlines but that is something that
happens in the real world the new york
post totally does that but at the same
time he also lectures peter parker on
libel in fact as a kid that's where i
first learned the difference between
libel and slander and then the third
movie he totally fires eddie brock over
plagiarism and goes to the length of
printing a retraction and then and far
from home that makes the daily bug a
direct parody of alex jones infowars i'm
just saying that when it comes to
whatever these movies want to say about
journalism they normally put a ton of
thought into the way they depict the
daily bugle but here i'm like christ you
couldn't even reduce the kerning between
the b and the a
anyway i'm just saying maybe this slop
could have been an intentional rush job
like the bugle could have been forced to
rush this front page out under pressure
from corporate interests in order to
ruin a dr michael morbius's reputation
as much as possible as quickly as
possible and then this park where
morbius was meeting with jared harris's
character is now swarmed by police and
here stroud wears a kind of bionic
enhancement on his arm maybe something
that assists with his vampire hunting
like retractable wooden steak claws or
with that tubing may be something that
could extract more beast's blood then
agent rodriguez references that thing in
san francisco likely referring to the
events of the first venom film set in
san francisco
remember that when the light foundation
was exposed for human testing using
alien goo but i don't know if this
universe is connected to the mcu or even
other spider verses would that crime
really be the biggest event these fbi
agents would be referencing over the
past few years i mean depending on how
deep in the mcu this movie is going to
try to be we did have a freaking blip
and then arguably even bigger in san
francisco you had giant man swimming
around in the bay and ant-man the wasp
you had buses flying all over the street
in chiang chi which we know from the
social media that movie was a viral
event but here shroud finds an origami
bat i'm guessing a kind of calling card
left behind by morbius at the sights of
his good deeds but it looks like it was
folded from a note containing his
chemical equations from his lab maybe a
message for the agents that he wants him
to find moving on
hey dr mike you and i should stay in
touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
morbius flees pass graffiti of
spider-man with murderer written on it
now this spider-man was actually a
throwback to the tobey maguire era suit
from the ps4 game loading screen
murderer though would imply the mcu
peter parker who in no way home is
facing public scrutiny and accusations
that he murdered mysterio but like this
movie's references to venom and to the
ozcorp logo design it's just more
evidence suggesting that morbius is
taking place in some fusion of all of
these realities and that's especially
true for the big cameo by michael keaton
as adrian toombs vulture still in his
white jumpsuit from the spider-man
homecoming post-credits scene which of
course is in the mcu so i guess this
movie's implication is when venom
transported into the mcu in the let
there be carnage post-credit scene he
now exists in a reality where venom has
always existed as tom hardy eddie brock
something that people know and that
could be the sony's way of explaining
how it is that alfred molina doc just
knows tom holland peter and how michael
keaton vulture knows dr mike here either
way i do like how the police lights
flash red and blue on their faces the
color of the webhead hero that whips
them together then morbius is fired upon
by guards bullets that morbius dodges
matrix style this actually looks like it
could be part of an extended kingsman
style long take that goes in and out of
slow motion next clip
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
okay stroud appears to be talking
morbius down while he holds his neck
suggesting he was either just swiped
there or maybe even bitten on his neck
then there's this nurse who flees and
fear down a corridor and in one of the
flashes of light you can see a grey claw
grabbing her neck this could be morbius
but it also could be the vampiric form
of crown moving on
a massive swarm of bats fills the space
at first the camera is actually shown
from the point of view of one of those
bats and then at the center of it all is
morbius's form you can actually see a
glimpse of purple behind him probably
part of his classic purple cape from the
comics and then we see morbius's nasty
boy roar it looks like he's got some
fresh blood on his teeth telling us that
he might have just taken a bite out of
something or someone let's hope it was
crime and then we get the title which
like all the title texts in this trailer
has its inner life force lowered until
it turns red drained like blood from a
vampire bite and then on to the last
clip
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service okay morbius
foils what looks like a counterfeiting
operation you can see large printers and
hundred dollar bill designs on the
screens morpheus is impersonating venom
here so we must be aware of that lethal
protector from the west coast and how he
delivers vigilante justice with that
terrifying monster face wink i guess
it's their equivalent of uh
i can't pull that off now in terms of
world logic it's just another curveball
right i mean i don't know has this
morbius met venom or is venom just like
a famous vigilante in this world that
people like to quote am i wasting my
time questioning cinematic universe
continuity when the studio thinks you
can just reverse engineer this all with
graffiti a few jokes a newspaper and
throwing money at michael keaton i don't
know like folks i think the doors had it
right people are strange hey you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you